my name is emma hiley i'm the acting
executive business director at glamour
magazine
today i'm going to be trying jaw fillers
with dr dre
which are not actually jaw fillers but
more on that later
can you let me know before don't worry
you won't
feel anything the older i get the more
it takes to achieve a certain
standard or i do have an idea about how
i want to look as much as i want to sort
of
embrace the whole body positivity thing
if i'm being really honest
emma i want to ask you
what is your concern my concern is these
i don't know if you can see these bits
here beneath the corners of my
mouth sag a bit so
i would love to see a bit more
definition in my jaw
now i will draw in your jawline
that is a device to see if you have
veins just to avoid the veins
okay you let me know before it
don't worry you won't feel anything okay
thank you whose opinions of how i look
matter to me i mean more and more that's
just
it's just me that it matters to what i
get up and go out the door feeling like
in the morning that's that's what
matters
are you okay i'm good i go very slowly
okay everything is very good you know
hey here it hurts a little bit yeah okay
finish
i know this looks quite extreme but it
wasn't painful it was a weird feeling
because you have the sensation of
pushing and pulling underneath your skin
which is
peculiar but not actually painful finish
perfect perfect it's actually very
important
because we can't spread the product it's
not pain
when you put it in it's just the feeling
of yeah because you're not used to
more defined here yeah and you are more
up
from here yeah i feel like i can see my
my jaw again
yeah you can see no more double chin
do i feel pressured about beauty
standards i think all women
whether they admit it or not absolutely
everyone does so this mask is a mask
with collagen and hyaluronic acid
it removes the redness so for me
the cost was 500 pounds per syringe
and there was also some hyaluronic acid
that went in the chin
and so the total was two thousand one
hundred pounds
you literally sit up and you can see a
difference straight away dr
showed me the mirror and i i could see
already that this
area here my lower part of my face looks
less
sad for wonderful better word i want to
go back because
you know maybe i'm not symmetrical but
this i would like maybe a bit more
here but overall
pretty good
you